an explosive development in the hunter
biden saga
the president-elect's son says his tax
affairs
are under federal investigation and
according to a brand new report
the justice department paused this probe
into hunters taxes in the months prior
to the presidential election
the biden transition releasing a
statement from hunter that reads in part
quote
i take this matter very seriously but i
am confident that a professional
and objective review of these matters
will demonstrate that i handled my
affairs legally
and appropriately including with the
benefit of
professional tax advisors and the biden
harris transitions saying
president-elect biden is deeply proud of
his son
who has fought through difficult
challenges including the vicious
personal attacks
of recent months only to emerge
stronger all right judge jeanine let's
start with you this
kind of jives with the reporting that we
did before the election that there was
indeed an
active investigation into hunter biden
now hunter has confirmed it what say you
well what i say is that this can't
possibly be
simply a tax investigation without
expanding into some of the more
international
uh accumulation of monies that hunter
biden collected for example when he went
to china and got that 1.5
billion dollars from a uh the chinese
communist party connected bank
as well as the money that he got in
ukraine and
and i understand it's romania and a few
other places
so um i think that two things that it's
got to expand beyond
just this country number one and i think
number two the idea of a special counsel
is certainly
very interesting because it's going to
be very difficult for
any united states attorney who is
working ultimately
if joe biden you know takes the
presidency and the electors decide on
december 14
to investigate the president's son i
think also
that they can say this has nothing to do
with that laptop but
i know full well that tax investigations
involve every piece of paper you have
ever touched every purchase you've ever
made every airline ticket there is
nothing that is out of bounds for these
investigators
and it all has to be looked at
completely and totally
and this is a guy you know to say he
believes that everything is an order
it sounds crazy because he's so out of
it he left his laptop at the uh
uh you know at a uh repair facility and
forgot it
yeah uh maraldo i would assume that the
judge is right this isn't a simple
turbo tax mistake like he he uploaded
his taxes on the internet and
didn't carry the one this is a guy
that's doing
dozens of international business deals
for decades
through wire transfers i can imagine
that there are a lot
of things to look at here by federal
investigators
at the very least hunter biden is a
parasite he's been sucking the
the blood off his father's uh his
father's official duties
uh it's never as janine as judge janine
says very accurately
it's never just a tax matter he's a hot
mess attacks uh probes like this
are like a malignancy they're a cancer
that grows and grows and grows
until it infiltrates every aspect of
every shady deal
he ever did uh it is to me ironic
that like the trump administration the
biden administration is
beginning under these uh these uh awful
circumstances
now uh the uh this uh the the the shadow
the dark shadow of this uh of his son's
troubles
will uh will definitely take the luster
off a lot of uh
the biden uh the beginning of the biden
presidency
uh he's in real trouble uh you know
hearing stories about
uh chinese business people leaving
jewels under the pillow in his hotel
and uh other undeclared income like that
you know it's going to be it's going to
be big and bad for hunter
it's going to embarrass the
president-elect and this will
taint i think the beginning of the 46th
president's term in office this is a
very big deal i'm glad
uh the father still loves the sun
because this son is a screw-up
he's been a screw-up his whole life he's
cut corners uh he's uh he's taken money
that he didn't earn
from coast to coast from continent to
continent uh and now it seems the uh
you know it's all come the chicken has
come home to roost there uh jesse
indeed yeah it could be an awkward
dinner at the biden household over
christmas vacation greg how do you think
the media
is going to begin to cover this new
development with hunter and his father
uh they won't uh they i i
you know it's funny it's like hunter is
a walking episode
of law and order i mean you've got sex
you got drugs you got strippers you got
videotape
you've got mystery people coming in and
out it's amazing though
how the media finds hunter beneath them
and i mean that figuratively not
literally although it could be possible
with hunter you never know
can i say this though i'll say this for
the five o'clock audience
payback is a pregnant dog
because that's what you're going to see
right now you're going to see
payback in every shape and you know what
i i i'm not i'm not a vengeful person
but mueller spent two years in 32
million dollars
chasing something that didn't take place
involving a country whose gdp
was roughly that of texas okay
russia was nothing compared to china
china's economy arguably is now bigger
than ours
and they are ruthless they have
concentration camps going right now
they've got our tech giants they've got
our professional sports teams
they've got entertainers and politicians
always already defending them
and why is that it it should it should
raise your concerns that china china is
so
happy that joe biden is coming in
and that is not good news for america
when your number one
adversary on this planet is ecstatic
that you're
that you have a new team captain and the
new team captain is joe biden
that's kind of scary so i think that i
think that the judge is right that
that this isn't really this isn't about
taxes
we've got to look into these
relationships that hunter had with china
uh trying to get about 10 million
dollars in exchange for making
introductions which i assume was joe
biden who was the big guy
we're talking i mean this administration
is already compromised they're more
compromised
than a preacher after a four-day bender
in vegas with jesse
just threw my name in there like that at
the end i did not see that coming
um yes dana perrino it does look like
china is now going to dog the biden
administration
probably worse than russia uh substa you
know substantively
because it does look like there's a lot
more material there how do you think
joe biden will handle something like
this he can't
fire the prosecutor can he
well actually i'm curious about that
because every president has the ability
to um fire the u.s attorneys most
presidents do
fire all the u.s attorneys and then you
appoint new us attorneys
um to the to that position now some u.s
attorneys do stay on
i i don't we don't know enough about
this this this investigation apparently
started
um back in 2018 i believe so
it depends on if it was a career public
official that was
handling this that's going to be very
dicey and if i were the incoming biting
administration
i wouldn't touch that with a 10-foot
pole but jesse
do you know who is the most happy person
right now
about this hunter biden news
congressman eric swalwell i said the
same thing
oh we're going to get to school in a
second
he's not off the camera
yes i agree but in a way those two
stories are very connected
because they both involve the same
country the same kind of shady
dealings the same kind of money
yes yes but if you're eric swalwell you
would much prefer
for you know for the present incoming
president's son
to be the one getting the headlines and
24 hours after
you were getting the headlines jessie
can i say one thing
all the insurance most incoming
presidents request
all of the us attorneys to hand in their
resignations
and what bill maher tried to do by
claiming that the special counsel
uh uh for uh john durham i mean special
counsel can be dismissed in a second
by the sitting attorney general so don't
don't be confident that this thing
won't be covered up either
but you know what the media the media is
going to cheer
the media is going to cheer when he is
going away
this is different this is this is
different when you hope so when it's all
about not paying your taxes
at the very least you're in a big jam
well all right keep following that
supposed to be a big one